[Music]
our Brooklyn Beckham and chloë grace
moretz back together all Clues point to
yes let's just be real the two reunited
in Ireland on Saturday where Chloe is
filming her new movie the window and it
seems safe to say the young lovebirds
looked completely smitten
Chloe kicked off her day sipping
Guinness at a brewery with her brother's
Trevor and Colin then she was off to a
soccer match in Dublin with Brooklyn
where she took to Instagram stories to
show off his sweet smooch Moretz and
Beckham called it quits in September
2016 but the two sparked reconciliation
rumours earlier this month when they
both instagrammed very similar black and
white photos of themselves and left
flirty comments on each other's posts
it's official last May Moretz gushed
about her then bo2 et at the neighbours
to premiere he's a sweetie he's a good
boy
she also revealed how they first met
back in 2014
I think it's SoulCycle or something
random yeah and that's out as every
advert Hollywood loves story read this
all signs up
[Music]